[Musique]
bonjourour au revoir monsieur Belin et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Dominique fort bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ministre délégé chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Stéphane Vern de West
France bonjour Stéphane bonjour bonjour
Dom bonjour bonjour bonjour à vous on va
évidemment longuement parler du Congrès
des Maires Dominique fort commune
attaquée République menacée c'est le
thème de ce 105e congrès des mares qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui quelle réponse
allez-vous apporter à ses
mères les
réponses que nous allons apporter à
cette montée de la violence faite aux
élus on parle d'une augmentation
d'environ 15 %
elles ont déjà démarré ses réponses au
mois d'avril avec un Pack Sécurité que
je pourrais vous rappeler si vous le
souhaitez avec un plan de lutte contre
la violence faite aux élus qui a été mis
en place on va dire début juillet et
puis on va finir cette année sous ces
trois axes qui nous animent que sont le
mieux protégé
mieux mieux protégé et puis
surtout mieux sanctionné et en fait on
va s'appuyer sur une proposition de loi
du président buffet qui a été voté à
l'unanimité qui va monter la sanction
est-ce qu'il y aura des réponses
nouvelles je dis oou est-ce que vous
allez faire le bilan de ce que vous avez
déjà fait sur le sujet de la montée de
de la violence euh vous comprenez bien
que il s'assoit sur la montée de la
violence dans la société bien sûr et je
peux vous dire qu'elles en sont
l'origine d'après moi mais est-ce que
nous allons amener quelque chose de
nouveau dans ce congrès des mères sur ce
sujet non bien sûr nous allons écouter
parce que on pourra toujours progresser
sur le premier semestre 2024 mais là
l'échéance que nous attendons c'est
véritablement la sanction dire aussi que
que l'on a annoncé hier un numéro que
pourront appeler nos maères sur le champ
tout simplement de la protection
psychologique moi j'ai vu à l'issue des
émeutes des mères à qui les larmes sont
montées aux yeux et on a échangé sur
cette violence psychologique issue de
ces émeutes début juillet et donc oui on
a pensé c'est une de leur demand ce
numéro ver euh ben oui parce que
derrière ça peut donner lieu à à un
diagnostic il peut peut-être les
encourager familialement parce que il
n'est pas uniquement destiné aux maires
aux élus mais aussi à leur famille tu
quand la l'Association des maires de
France parle de commune attaqué vous
répondez violence faite aux élus est-ce
qu'il y a que ça c'est essentiellement
ça ou il y a d'autres d'autres points
qui sont sur la table en quoi les
communes se sentent attaqué aujourd'hui
commune attaquée ça sous-entend violence
faite aux élus oui mais pas que ça veut
dire aussi euh attaque au bien de la
collectivité on l'a vu au au mois de au
mois de juillet et surtout faut rappeler
que dans ces
1387 faits et c'est plus 15 % on ne va
trouver que moins de 5 % et heureusement
de violence faite au maires et aux élus
violence physique très peu heureusement
donc beaucoup d'attaqu au bien école on
l'a vu hein pendant les émettes donc
quelles sont les origines peut-être me
demandiez-vous oui non mais juste sur
les attaques au bien parce que les mares
doivent payer la reconstruction et il y
a des maires qui sont lâchés par les
assurance soit qu'il est lâche soit
qu'il leur demande des tarifs
exorbitants est-ce que vous avez les
moyens de faire pression sur les
assureurs qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
faire nous avons lancé une mission avec
Bruno Le Maire il y a moin environ avec
à la fois deux inspecteurs mais aussi un
maire euh à un chrétien et puis un
dirigeant d'une compagnie d'assurance et
c'est ce quitureur qui est en train de
travailler pour nous apporter des
solutions les compagnies d'assurances
sont confrontés à des dégâts énormes et
à devoir rembourser des travaux dans des
proportions euh qui sont qui ne sont
plus corrélés au risqu qu'ils ont pris
et euh il nous faut trouver un chemin
pour permettre à toutes collectivité qui
le souhaite de vouloir s'assurer mais en
même temps ne pas amener au dépôt de
bilan nos compagnies d'assurance ce qui
aurait pu être le cas de la Smage qui
disent que c'est plus rentable
aujourd'hui d'assurer les collectivités
exactement je vous prendre juste le
petit exemple de la SMAC vous savez euh
c'est une compagnie d'assurance une
mutuelle qui assure près de 80 % de nos
communes et elle rembourse de l'ordre de
4 millions d'euros de dégâts par an avec
les émeutes de fin juin début juillet
c'est autour de 46 millions d'euros
qu'elle doit rembourser donc il n'y a il
si la Maïf n'était pas venu au capital
de laasmacle à hauteur de 100 millions
d'euros ben laasmacle n'aurait pas pu
poursuivre et n'aurait plus ne serait
plus une mutuelle pérenne pour nos
collectivités qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand une municipalité n'arrive plus à
assurer c'est c'est bien ça arrive et
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ce est-ce
que ça arrive qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans ces cas elle s'autoassure en fait
la le cahier des charges est é mis et
puis parfois euh il n'y a personne qui
répond à l'appel d'offre que la
collectivité a lancé moi j'appelle les
les maires et les collectivités à
prendre en compte les rapports que les
compagnies d'assurance leur font sur
comment mieux protéger leurs biens et
souvent ça génère évidemment des frais
des travaux de maintenance on prend une
porte de gymnase qui a été forcée une
fois deux fois trois fois tro années de
suite ou 3 mois d'affilé il faut
remettre en cause euh tout simplement le
système de fermeture pour faire en sorte
que ce gymnase la porte ne soit plus
forcée et quelques communes
n'investissent pas suffisamment sur la
maintenance et donc forcément les
compagnies d'assurance ne répondent plus
cependant j'attends les résultats de
cette mission pour être en mesure de
voir quelles sont les solutions qui
s'offrent au ma et et mon idée est
véritablement qu'il y ait toujours une
solution quand il souhait s'assurer bien
sûr Stéphan on revient à la question
duol oui sur le plan de protection des
élus locaux vous évoquiez donc il il
avait été annoncé au printemps vous
dites qu'il a été mis en place début
juillet est-ce que le réseau de 3400
références gendarmes ou policiers a été
pleinement déployé ce jour tout
simplement
euh il s'agissait de des 3400 gendarmes
ou policiers référents élus qui existait
et euh
on formé et on leur a demandé d'être des
référents violences faites aux élus et
on leur a demandé d'accélérer l'allé
vert c'est vraiment aller à la rencontre
de tous les maires euh pour à la fois
travailler sur la prévention et à la
fois travailler sur la perception de
sécurité que le maire sa famille ses
collègues élus peut peut ressentir il
était question d'un dispositif alarme
élu un dispositif spécifique est-ce
qu'il a été utilisé si oui dans quelle
proportion il a été déployé dès le mois
de juillet je ne sais pas vous dire dans
quelle proportion il est utilisé vous
savez il y a deux façons
euh d'appeler à l'aide la première c'est
quand même le 17 après c assurer que son
numéro de portable est bien enregistré
et en appelant le 17 vous êtes certain
que vous serez traité prioritairement
comme une personne à risque ensuite si
la personne n'a pas son téléphone mobile
le dispositif alarme si elle se sent
menacé que le maire ou les élus ont sur
eux leur permet d'appeler cinq numéros
qui s'appellent
automatiquement et qui géolocalise là où
se trouve l'élu a-t-il été utilisé de
façon importante ou pas on l'a lancé il
y a quelques mois je saais vous le dire
d'ici quelques semaines au moins il éit
également question de mieux mieux
judiciariser les violences les violence
en ligne fait aux élus est-ce que ça ça
marche ça fonctionne aussi ou pas donc
c'est la proposition de loi du président
buffet qui a été voté à l'unanimité et
qui va être voté très probablement à
l'Assemblée à la fin de l'année ou au
tout début d'année donc ser examiné
quand juste à l'Assemblée elle devrait
donc passer 2e semaine de décembre si
impossible tout début janvier je vrais
quand même dire que que les sanctions
vont monter jusqu'à 100000 € d'amende et
7 ans d'emprisonnement ferme et la
sanction elle a souvent des vertus euh
de prévention
c'est-à-dire de faire savoir à ces
délinquants à quel point la sanction
peut être importante pour eux et pour
leur famille parce que on a vu que on
avait quelques délinquants mineurs et
l'autorité parentale doit jouer son rôle
est-ce que alors il y a l'autorité
parentale mais est-ce que face à ces
augment des violences des lules les
citoyens ont aussi un un rôle à jouer
j'ai appelé dès le mois de d'avril à un
choc civique et nous travaillons vous
avez l'impression qu'il até entendu ce
choc civique depuis quelques mois à
comment le mettre en
œuvre est-il entendu moi en tout cas je
fais régulièrement au côté de mes
rencontres avec les maires les élus
locaux je fais des rencontres citoyenne
j'en ai fait une la semaine dernière
avec Olivier verérrand il y avait une
petite centaine de citoyens et l'idée de
réfléchir est-ce que une réserve
citoyenne qui puisse être municipale et
est-elle la solution qui peut provoquer
ce choc civique c'est cette réserve
citoyenne ça pourrait être he puisque je
suis en phase d'investigation de
réflexion d'association de citoyens pour
savoir si ça peut être pertinent c'est
tout simplement faire appel à des
bénévoles et à des citoyens qui veulent
accompagner leur commune par rapport ort
à des services je prends toujours deux
exemples le premier c'est celui qui vise
accompagner des enfants à traverser
l'école et c'est toujours des coouts
très importants pour les maires et puis
les parents sont souvent pressés d'aller
travailler donc on peut pas mettre des
policiers municipaux devant tous les
groupes scolaire et pour accompagner ses
enfants c'est quelque chose qui est
sympathique qui crée du lien social et
qui pourrait intéresser quelques
citoyens seconde c'est des jardins
potagers qui pourraient être mis à la
disposition
par des communes auprès de citoyens et
pour ensuite ben redistribuer les fruits
de ce jardin et cette réserve citoyenne
elle aurait donc pour vertu
d'accompagner les élus locaux et de leur
faire prendre conscience à quel point la
République est menacée quand on
s'attaque à nos élus comme on le voit
aujourd'hui et en même temps elle
pourrait servir dans le cadre des
tempêtes ou des inondations que nous
avons eu dans le nord de la France a
peut-être mobilisé facilement parce que
ce serait des gens qui seraient mis à la
disposition de leur commune qui pourrai
se déplacer pour aller secourir euh des
des personnes qui feraient l'objet de de
sinistre il y a l'enquête du cvipov qui
a été publiée hier et qui révèle
notamment que les maires ont un
ressentiment sur les conditions
d'exercice de leur mission et sur la
question de leurs indemnités est-ce
qu'il faut augmenter les indemnités des
maires nous avons travaillé sur ce sujet
avec l'AMF d'abord puis toutes les
associations d'élus et plus récemment
dans la Convention nationale de
démocratie locale où vous le savez 350
maires sont venus
aujourd'hui je dirais que ils sont
unanimes euh et je pense que nous droit
de travailler plus finement maintenant
pour augmenter leur indemnité que ce
soit donc on va faire une augmentation
des indemnités on y va parce que ils
sont demandeurs le gouvernement
considère que cette générosité dont
historiquement euh qu'il portent en leur
sein quand on est ma on aime les gens et
il a cette générosité certains ne
prennent pas la totalité de l'indemnité
à laquelle ils ont droit certains la
redistribuent à leur conseillers
délégués
euh mais l'idée est véritablement de les
augmenter la le fait tous les niveaux
puisquil y a des différentes ananités en
fonction du N je pense que ça peut être
travaillé effectivement de façon très
large il faut arriver à défaut d'un
consensus à un compromis donc oui nous
allons poursuivre les travaux pour
savoir de combien bien à quel niveau
parce que on voit qu'il est de plus en
plus difficile de concilier la fonction
de maire avec un emploi et bien sûr avec
sa vie de famille et sur le sujet de de
la hausse de l'indamnité je veux quand
même rappeler sur l'inflation juste
c'est une des propositions du Sénat
d'indexer l'indemnité sur l'inflation
oui parce que à ce stade l'indemnité
elle n'est augmentée que par
l'augmentation du point d'indice des
fonctionnaires mais elle n'est pas
indexé sur l'inflation donc pour vous
c'est c'est c'est envisageable sur moi
je n'y suis pas favor mais je suis
ouverte à toute discussion sur le sujet
est-ce que les Français les Françaises
ont conscience que l'écrasante majorité
des maires ne vivent pas de ces
indemnités en fait quand vous êtes maire
d'une petite commune vous êtes obligé
d'avoir un emploi à côté est-ce que
est-ce que tout le monde a bien a bien
ça en tête combien combien il gagne le
maire d'un d'une d'un village
aujourd'hui enfin il gagne c'est pas le
bon terme mais c'est quoi son indemnité
donc jusqu'à 500 habitants donc nos plus
petites communes mais les plus
nombreuses en fait c'est ce que je vous
disais Jacqueline Gouro était ministre
des collectivités locales à ce moment-là
c'est la loi 3DS et on augmente cette
indemnité à 1000 € brut c'est-à-dire 800
€ net ensuite ça monte progressivement
de 500 à 1000 habitants donc on va
jusqu'à 1400 € brut et puis ça monte
jusqu'à sur la la tranche 1000 10000 on
est à autour de 2000 2200 € brut et puis
voilà ça monte progressivement la
réflexion elle doit vraiment être menée
sur toutes les strates encore une fois
pour les raisons que j'inoquais parce
que dans certains cas ben les maires ont
évidemment tous les moyens et ne sont
pas eux sollicités sur leur portable euh
et ne sont pas dans l'action du service
public sur leur commune parce que il y a
beaucoup d'agents et puis dans d'autres
cas ils n'ont pas d'agents et c'est eux
qui sont sollicités par est-ce que lors
de ce congrès il y aura des annonces sur
le statut de
l'élu alors je ne sais pas vous le dire
encore parce que s'il y avait annonce ça
serait la première ministre qui la
ferait en tout cas euh il y a vraiment
consensus me semble-t-il et c'est pour
ça que moi j'arrive dans ce congrès avec
vraiment le sentiment que le climat est
apaisé alors bien sûr la MF va sûrement
m'interpeller interpeller le
gouvernement mais le climat est apaisé
je le constate et la première ministre
est satisfaite du travail que nous avons
fait dont je viens de vous parler initié
avec la MF élargi à toutes les
association d'élus et les parlementaires
qui aboutit à on va dire deux notes que
j'ai faites à la première ministre la
première elle est sur le statut de l'élu
elle reprend beaucoup de ce que nos
maères nous ont demandé la seconde elle
est sur les conditions d'exercice du
mandat d'élu c'est-à-dire tous ces
irritants et je pense pas que nous ayons
le temps de produire des annonces
véritablement mais elle va au moins
annoncer sa détermination à trouver les
euh on va dire les créneau
parlementaires pour faire passer tout ce
qui relève du législatif le climat est
meilleur avec et bon avec les élus
dites-vous mais il y a quand même il y a
quand même plus de 1400 déémissions de
maire depuis les dernières élections
municipales 2020 c'est beaucoup quel
quels sont les les vous vous parlez
d'héritant quelles sont les principales
raisons selon vous qui font qu'il y a un
nombre impressionnant de maires qui
jettent l'éponge avant même d'avoir
commencé quasiment beaucoup de ces
démissions sont des maires élus depuis
2020 euh sont des maires qui découvrent
à quel point le mandat de mare et quelle
que soit la strate euh les absorbe dans
leur totalité
pour beaucoup d'entre eux parce que je
les reçois euh pour ceux qui euh ont le
temps dans leur vie professionnelle
qu'ils ont reprise quand ils ont
démissionné de venir échanger et
expliquer la raison principale c'est la
charge de travail la charge
administrative la complexité
administrative et c'est pour ça que je
me suis attelé à c'est pas les violences
faites enfin contre les élus c'est pas
des problèmes d'indemnité c'est vraiment
le le le l'empilement de règles et
souvent l'incompatibilité avec la vie de
famille et avec un emploi et quel que
soit le montant des indemnités que nous
pourrions
euh augmenter euh de toute façon
beaucoup d'entre eux euh sont obligés de
continuer à travailler et donc travail
mandat de mare et vie familiale il se
rendent compte à quel point c'est
difficile et puis vous savez émerge euh
souvent la question et pourquoi ne
pourrions-nous pas indemniser les maires
à la hauteur euh de leur rémunération
professionnel c'est c'est juste
impossible parce qu'il y a une telle
disparité dans les fonctions qu'occupent
les maires avant de devenir maire que ça
n'est pas pensable c'est pas possible
Stéphane sur la décentralisation
oui il y a est-ce que les on peut parler
d'autres échelons que que les maires
est-ce que est-ce que les les régions
doivent s'inquiéter de la la mission
confiée par Emmanuel Macron à Eric vert
est-ce qu'il y aura est-ce qu'il y aura
un découpage ou un redécoupage dans
l'air des des grandes régions que sont
aurat occitan grand test ou nouvelle
Aquitaine par exemple euh les raisons
les les nos élus n'ont pas de raison de
s'inquiéter
aucuneien est euh pour ce qui est des
départements la première ministre a été
claire à l'assemblée générale des
départements de France Erric vert a été
très clair lorsqu'il accompagnait le
président aux rencontres de Saint-Denis
il n'y aura pas de suppression des
départements ou d'une quelconque strate
aujourd'hui donc pr de strat non ça a
été
clairement pour les départements mais
voyez-vous
intercommunalité département région non
suppression des régions il n'y aura pas
la suppression des rég la question du
redécoupage elle se elle est elle est
sur la table alors moi je n'ai pas
entendu aujourd'hui de réflexion sur le
redécoupage des
régions moi je pense que pour les
régions les plus grandes cela a beaucoup
de sens de par la concurrence que nous
avons en Europe avec les régions
allemandes avec les régions espagnoles
comme vous savez moi je suis d'origine
toulousaine et fier de cette région
Occitanie qui peut rivaliser avec la
région Catalogne qui est extrêmement
forte économiquement donc oui des
régions fortes sur leurs compétences que
sont les transports que sont la
recherche l'innovation que sont le
développement économique on a besoin de
régions fortes donc mais mais juste sur
cette mission je présumer de ce que sera
les résultats de la mission sur cette
mission parce que on entend parler de
décentralisation depuis le les les
premiers mois du premier quinquenat
d'Emmanuel Macron vous devez avoir sur
votre bureau un nombre incalculable de
propositions notamment qui viennent du
Sénat puisque le Sénat a fait plusieurs
propositions du coup quel est l'intérêt
de cette mission est-ce que n'est pas
venu le temps de
l'action vous savez le le 20e siècle a
été le siècle dans lequel on a
décentralisé et plusieurs actes de
décentralisation qui nous ont amené à la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui je pense que le
président appelle de ses vœux beaucoup
plus de lisibilité et je pense que quand
il indique à quel point il aimerait que
quand le citoyen vote pour la région il
sache pourquoi et pour quelle compétence
il vote quand il vote pour le
département de même donc il y ait besoin
de faire des ajustements sur le champ de
la lisibilité entre l'État les régions
les départements les intercommunalités
les maires je dis oui qu'il y ait besoin
d'ajustement qu' besoin c'est ça vous
avez besoin Miss oui tout simplement
parce que aujourd'hui euh il ne vous a
pas échappé que l'on a traversé trois
crises majeures et que notre
gouvernement euh est quand même
extrêmement au travail pour accompagner
nos citoyens nos élus locaux dans dans
dans la traversée de ces crises donc oui
un député expérimenté que Eric vert
mandaté pour faire des recommandations
concrètes à la première ministre au
président de la République bien sûr moi
je trouve que ça a du sens ensuite il a
évoqué le nombre de rencontres qu'il
allait faire pour nous nourrir sa
réflexion je pense qu'il va aussi aller
voir ce qui se passe dans les pays
étrangers moi-même j'étais en Espagne et
au Portugal pour voir comment cela
fonctionn je pense que ça peut conduire
à une efficacité et comme vous l'appelez
de vos vœux un passage à l'action
dernière question Stéphane vous vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure les les les
irritants les sujets qui agacent les les
élus locaux quel que soit le le
l'échelon en ce moment c'est qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui crée des tensions entre
entre l'État et les élus locaux toute
catégorie confondu euh plus de tension
les deux grandes natures d'irritant
c'est d'abord la recherche de
subventions où ils sont obligés
d'instruire des dossiers pour l'État
pour la région pour le département
parfois pour leur intercommunalit les
question d'argent ça reste une source de
tension alors pas l'argent lui-même mais
la complexité des dossiers à instruire
pour aller chercher ces subventions tous
les maires appellent de leur vœux une
simplification et surtout un travail
plus étroit pour essayer de faire en
sorte surtout les plus petites communes
qui n'ont pas les moyens de porter ces
dossiers ensuite les sujets que vous
connaissez du Zéro artificialisation net
bien sûr de la ZFE
au-delà de l'adhésion à l'objectif que
nous portons d'être plus sobre sur le
plan du foncier d'être plus
écologiquement responsable ils appellent
de leur vœux moins de ce qu'ils
appellent des injonction contradictoire
donc il nous faut travailler avec les
parlementaires mais aussi avec les élus
locaux pour pour faire évoluer les
choses pour que les choses soient plus
simples ah ben mercique fort j'aurais pu
vous laisser finir votre phrase merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec nous à
la de West France du positif ces
initiatives locales rendent la vie plus
douce et on découvre la Fédération des
trucs qui marchent Stéphane et oui les
trucs qui marchent c'est important d'en
parler et on en parlera dans la rue de
presse merci beaucoup merci Stéphane
merci Dominique fort d'avoir été avec
nous on pass au club des territoires